[Music]
[Applause]
in a huge open world like night city
you need a chill ride to get around fast
and in cyberpunk 2077 there are tons of
cool vehicles to choose from
get this four liter engine six cylinder
goes from zero to a hundred and three
point two seconds you [ __ ] believe
that
[Music]
we've crafted every car and motorbike
with amazing attention to details
on the chassis the body not to mention
the interiors
you can expect everyone not only to look
unique but to deliver a unique driving
experience
all right show me what you got
don't expect advanced tech or luxurious
materials here
[Music]
yeah it's not the size that counts i
guess
this class is mostly utility vehicles
and low end clunkers made for
every pocket hold on hold on it's a
wreck
my damn wreck well definitely no guy or
girl max
[Music]
if you need to impress look to this
class alone
[Music]
i put my ride on the line either you
match it in cash
but you can forget about the fight
with these wheels no expense has been
spared no frill ignored
their plush interiors decked out in all
the latest tech
while you get to sit back and enjoy the
ride
masterful engineering and practical
design trucks and
tanks for when you need power and brute
force
hell the machine neat beast
my pride and joy and these monsters are
literally
unstoppable
these are fortunes who love the smell of
exhaust and the roar of street wildlife
their powerful engines and exchangeable
parts make them perfect for tuning
come on
[Applause]
whether it's street racing running from
the ncpd
or just showing off in the streets with
these high-powered beasts
you will have only respect
oh yeah i like that if you need
speed and armor the hyper car class is
for you it means precise bodywork
built-in lidar arrays and really
expensive materials
imagine you're sitting on a pile of
eddies probably less than a thousand
people in the world can afford to air
indict
not your typical urban vehicle
they will take you places you never
dreamed you'd go
oh and original vehicles are not all
you'll find in 2077.
we also found room on our roster for
some true
automotive icons floor it v
[Music]